Dungeons and Dragons has altered the
deal prey they do not alter it any
further because for years Wizards of the
Coast which publishes Dungeons and
Dragons has operated under an open
gaming license in ogl that allowed
people to create and profit from
unofficial content in the Dungeons and
Dragons universe or does it it's time to
think like a rules lawyer the idea is
that the ogl is a legal framework that
allows people to use the rules and ideas
of the role-playing games to create
their own works and it was originally
released in the year 2000s by Wizards of
the Coast and a lot of people have come
to rely on the terms of the ogl to make
and publish their own content under the
Aegis of Wizards of the Coast but that
was version one of the ogl now according
to a leak version 1.1 of the ogl which
has not officially been adopted makes
huge sweeping changes that will affect
anyone that makes content even related
to Dungeons and Dragons but this leaked
version 1.1 update to the ogl is a mixed
bag it purports to crack down on sexist
homophobic and transphobic content that
is created with the Dungeons and Dragons
name it purports to Grant a Perpetual
license to Wizards of the Coast for
anyone that makes content using that
license it purports to require certain
people who make content using that
license to report that usage to Wizards
of the Coast and if you make over 750
000 in Revenue you have to pay certain
royalties up to 25 percent to Wizards of
the Coast on certain marginal income
these are big changes now it's important
to distinguish the ogl from the actual
Dungeons and Dragons rules the Dungeons
and Dragons operates under a set of
rules that's up to version 5e at this
point and the ogl is not the Dungeons
and Dragons rules and generally speaking
those rules are found in the system
reference document the SRD that's a 400
page document containing just about
everything you need to know about
playing DND the main benefit of the ogl
whether you're talking about version one
or version 1.1 is that it allows people
to use and reproduce the SRD the rules
but for people who make content that
just simply works with the rules but
doesn't reproduce them well there's a
big question about whether you need the
ogl at all now we'll come back to that
later now these sweeping changes caused
a huge uproar among fans and content
creators alike but like I said it's a
mixed bag on the plus side it provides a
relatively clear path to allow almost
anyone to create officially licensed
content and that's pretty rare it's not
like Disney says sure you can make any
Mickey Mouse content you want just pay
us if you happen to make over 750 000 in
revenue and if these changes were coming
from a position of absolute restriction
like Disney has a lockdown on their IP
then people would probably Rejoice that
they have this Pathway to make
officially licensed content and profit
from it but as it stands we're coming
from the opposite we're coming from a
world where almost everything was
totally open and these restrictions are
causing a lot of consternation so many
people are upset about this leaked
modified ogl and the leaked ogl
differentiates between commercial and
non-commercial content people making
non-commercial content are fairly
unburdened and the leak says that making
money via patreon doesn't necessarily
count as commercial so that probably
covers a large swath of people who might
otherwise be upset about these changes
now I'm not going to dive too deep into
the changes of this ogl it's reasonably
easy to understand to the credit of the
lawyers who drafted it and a lot of the
coverage has already described what the
implication of these purported changes
are and there are some issues as far as
enforceability and promissory estoppel
and Reliance
can you revoke a license that was
granted in perpetuity I'm not going to
get into those for a more detailed
breakdown of the contractual Provisions
themselves I'd highly recommend you
check out the Nerds over at opening
arguments they really go into the
details of what the original and the
leaked ogl say and what they don't say
it's absolutely the best breakdown of
the contracts themselves but I also
think almost everyone is missing the
biggest issue and what I want to cover
today is one of the more fundamental
flaws with this whole setup and I think
frankly it changes everything and as it
happens this whole controversy is a
perfect opportunity to teach people
about the difference between copyright
and trademark so so you know win-win but
the original ogl has been around for a
while and it was intended to provide an
open platform for players and for some
of the critical background on that
history I turned to the DND expert and
ubernerd Matt Koval the products that
they make for Dungeons and Dragons tend
um to sell best to players well
adventurers don't make a lot of money
because only one of the four or five
players at the table buy them but you
still got to make them so his argument
was why don't we open these rules and
make it so that people anybody can make
products for us and that way third-party
companies will come along and they will
make Adventures for us and they'll make
other stuff too but we don't care and
that way they'll support our product and
there was also some
um verbiage in there about how and if
those companies improve our rules and
it's published under the ogl then we can
take those improvements right and then
our game will improve and that was you
know very egalitarian way of looking at
things and then fast forward and wizard
of the coast releases a fourth edition
which um was very controversial and
alienated a lot of fans and so they sort
of freaked out and really least a fifth
edition fourth edition wasn't released
under the open gaming license it was
released under a different license
called the GSL which was much more
draconic and restrictive and then fifth
edition was released under the uh under
the old ogl which was much more open and
Broad and empowers people to make the
stuff they want privately the reason
Ryan said he wanted to talk the board
into opening
um d d was because he did not like the
idea that any one company would control
this Hobby
like he was like I don't think I think
Dean bu should belong to everybody and
this is the best way I can think of to
make that happen d d is I think more of
a folk tradition and a hobby than it is
a classical brand and it has always
relied on the people who play it more so
than any other game I can think of
except you know perhaps like Skyrim
right where there's so many mods for it
it's always relied on the audience to
create content for it things like the
thief
come from people playing in Los Angeles
and coming to a new class and literally
calling up Gary gigax on the phone and
saying hey we got this cool idea and
he's like oh that's cool I'd probably do
it like this and all of a sudden there's
a thief in the game right so that
relationship between the players and the
people making the game has always been a
lot more gray and weirdly nuanced than
almost any other game I can think of
okay so with that background out of the
way let's talk about the difference
between copyright and trademark I
promise it will be worth it now
copyright is a certain legal protection
for expression when you have an original
work of authorship whether it is a movie
or a novel and you affix it to a
tangible medium well then copyright will
protect that expression copyright does
not protect ideas it does not protect
processes it protects expression whether
that expression is in a form of words or
a painting or a video copyright will
provide quite a lot of protection
trademark is about serving to identify
the source of a particular product or
service to distinguish that product from
other sellers in the marketplace the
idea with trademark is you don't want
consumers confused you want people to
actually know what they're buying at the
time of sale and trademark is a little
bit different and it can last forever as
long as someone is actually selling the
trademark good that trademark will
continue for the protection of consumers
now Dungeons and Dragons as a tabletop
RPG product involves both it contains
copyrightable pieces of expression as
well as trademarkable elements that are
meant to identify it in the marketplace
let's use a board game that everyone is
familiar with Monopoly as an example
here the name Monopoly is trademarked
there is a long history of the Monopoly
trademark that dealt with years and
years of litigation let's put it aside
for the moment the logo of Monopoly is
also trademarked the official Monopoly
board the actual squares and everything
on it that's copyrighted that is
expression it's as if it were a painting
and then some times within board games
you have specifically detailed
characters that can be copyrighted for
example in Monopoly Rich Uncle Penny
bags is a copyrighted character and in
clue you have Colonel Mustard those are
copyrighted characters
but the name of the game Monopoly is
trademarked so you can't go out there
and create a game called Monopoly and
sell it even if the rules of the game
are completely different but what about
the opposite what if you created a game
that had a different name but followed
the same rules as another game well that
takes us to the fundamental flaw of this
whole entire controversy which is that
you can't copyright the rules to a game
you can't copyright a process now this
goes back to an extremely old copyright
Supreme Court case uh in the late 19th
century called Baker versus Selden where
someone tried to copyright a particular
method of bookkeeping in that case a guy
created a method of bookkeeping I.E
accounting and published a book about it
the book did okay but it really took off
when another person created another book
of basically just forms that used the
same methodology but didn't credit the
original person the original author sued
but the Supreme Court said that there
was no copyright available because you
can't copyright a method and that idea
was later codified in the Copyright Act
of 1976 which said quote in no case does
copyright protection for an original
work of authorship extend to any idea
procedure process system method of
operation concept principle or Discovery
regardless of the form in which it is
described explained Illustrated or
embodied in such work so for example if
you wondered why everyone could play the
game Words With Friends on Facebook even
though it was an exact clone of Scrabble
well that's the reason Scrabble can't
have copyright protection over the rules
of the game it can only really get
trademark protection over the name
Scrabble not the rules contained therein
now there is a little bit of a wrinkle
here in the sense that if you had a
manual of rules you do get a thin
copyright over the exact expression over
the rules as laid out in that rule book
however you don't get a copyright over
the rules and processes themselves so in
a sense you can have something that has
exactly the same mechanics the same
processes it just can't necessarily have
the exact same expression if you were to
reproduce the rules perfectly but that's
kind of a minor quibble so how does this
relate to the Wizards of the Coast
update to the ogl well I think and I
could be wrong that Wizards of the Coast
is assuming that anytime anyone creates
any content that happens to use the
rules of Dungeons and Dragons that is
covered by the ogl
I don't think that's the case now this
is not legal advice your mileage may
vary but as we discussed you can't
copyright the rules you can't copyright
the methodology and processes and that
takes us to the thing that no one is
talking about here's part of the secret
the original ogl kinda sucks and here's
why the main benefit of the ogl was that
it allowed people to include the SRD the
system reference document in their
material if your material doesn't
require a reprinting or quoting of the
SRD or the 5e rules then you probably
don't need the ogl the original ogl
allowed people to use what it called
quote open game content meaning quote
the game mechanic and includes the
methods procedures processes and
routines to the extent such content does
not embody the product identity now it
did not allow people to use quote
product identity meaning quote product
and product line names logos identifying
marks including trade dress artifacts
creatures characteristics stories story
lines plots thematic elements dialogue
incidents language artwork symbols
design lines et cetera et cetera et
cetera so based on what we've already
discussed here I'm not sure that there
was much benefit to the original ogl it
mainly allowed you to use stuff that you
were already allowed to use unless you
wanted to actually quote the expression
that was found in the SRD itself and the
new ogl does basically the same thing
the leaked ogl allows licensed people to
use quote licensed content it says
usable DND content quote license content
this is Dungeons and Dragons content
that is included in the SRD version 5.1
including basic game mechanics a curated
selection of classes monsters spells and
items that allow you to make content
compatible with Dungeons and Dragons 5th
edition and then the new ogl goes on to
say not usable DND content quote
unlicensed content this is Dungeons and
Dragons content that has been or later
will be produced as official that is
released by Wizards of the Coast or any
of its predecessors or successors and is
not present in the SRD version 5.1
unlicensed content includes things like
the most famous Dungeons and Dragons
monsters characters magic spells and
things related to the various settings
used in dungeons dragons official
content over the years what the old open
license content referred to as quote
product identity so both ogl's purported
to let you use game mechanics of
Dungeons and Dragons and in my view
that's stuff that everyone was always
allowed to use but of course the benefit
of the ogls whether it's version 1 or
version 1.1 is that it provides
certainty so there's that but let's
differentiate between two different
types of content in one bucket you'll
have what I'll call reproduction content
and in the other bucket you have what I
would call a Homebrew content in this
first reproduction bucket you have
things that would probably be considered
from a copyright perspective derivative
works that is works that are based on a
copyrighted property that Wizards the
coast owns so for example if you made a
t-shirt that features a character that
is based on an official Wizards of the
Coast Dungeons and Dragons campaign and
you put that on a t-shirt even if you
paint it yourself well that's probably a
derivative work and you need to get the
permission of wizards the coast and to
their credit Wizards the coast has a fan
art policy that allows fans to create
fan art and this is on their website and
I don't think it's changed but also in
this bucket is stuff that reproduces the
the SRD remember I said that they do
have a copyright over the actual exact
wording that's in the SRD and recall
that both the original ogl and version
1.1 allow people to reproduce the SRD so
if your livelihood relies on actually
reproducing the expression of the SRD
you would need to abide by the terms of
the ogl and I don't think that has
changed and maybe you want to quote
large sections of the SRD to put it into
a reference manual or maybe you want to
put the entire SRD into a PDF along with
your original content say if you created
an entirely new set of rules but it
starts with a basis of the SRD and you
don't want to have people referencing
back to the old SRD well that is
probably covered and to their credit
both versions of the ogl allows people
to do that if you want to quote the SRD
it creates a pathway for that but this
reproductive bucket consists of things
that are based on things that Wizards of
the Coast can actually copyright in the
second bucket and this is the thing that
I I think most people are upset about
would be home brewed adventures and
campaigns whose only connection to
Wizards of the Coast is the fact that
they use the rules in Dungeons and
Dragons 5e in this bucket I'm kind of
thinking about the things that you see
on critical role or Dimension 20 where
they create a campaign that is 100
original the characters are completely
new the settings are completely new and
the only connection that these campaigns
have to Dungeons and Dragons and Wizards
of the Coast is that they rely on the
rules that are set out in Dungeons and
Dragons 5e as we discussed I don't think
Wizards of the Coast has much protection
over the rules themselves the processes
and methodologies contained in the
Dungeons and Dragons rules so if you
create an otherwise original campaign
where the only connection is the fact
that it uses the rules that are set out
in d d 5e I don't think that runs a foul
of the ogl in fact I don't think you
need permission from Wizards of the
Coast in any case even if you videotape
and live stream that campaign I don't
think you need their permission because
at the end of the day wizard to the
coast doesn't really have any kind of Ip
protection over the rules themselves now
admittedly there's a lot of gray area
here because it's not as simple as one
bucket for fan art and one bucket for
home brew Wizards of the Coast and d d
has all kinds of different characters
some are pre-made now arguably those
characters are often in the service of
the mechanics of the game they Define
the strength or speed or dexterity of
these particular characters but there's
also a backstory there so does that
create the kind of character that is
protected like Colonel Mustard or James
Bond or is that simply a rule in the
game that functions within that
rule-based universe that's a tough
question but I'm also skeptical that the
changes to the ogl affect virtual
tabletops or kickstarters as well again
the virtual tabletops are basically
using the mechanics of the rules
themselves elves which I don't think
Wizards of the Coast has much protection
over and same with kickstarters over
original campaigns and Adventures you
know again if you're creating an
entirely original world that just simply
happens to use the rules of Dungeons and
Dragons I'm not sure that there's uh
much that Wizards of the Coast can do
about that though at the same time if
you are trying to do a Kickstarter over
something that Wizards of the Coast
actually has protection over if you
wanted to crowdsource a movie based on
uh the Mythos and and lore of Dungeons
and Dragons that probably is going to be
covered by the ogl though another gray
area where I'm not sure where a court
would come down would be say live
streaming a playthrough of an official
Wizards the coast Dungeons and Dragons
campaign obviously Wizards of the Coast
publishes a number of official Dungeons
and Dragons campaigns and if you live
streamed you and your friends playing
through that that is using official
Dungeons and Dragons content over which
they do have the copyright that's a
tough call though I would say that's
analogous to live streaming a
playthrough of a video game which which
is also kind of a gray area a video game
is copyrighted and it's an open question
whether you're playing through it is
adding enough original content to be
covered by fair use and the same would
go for playing through Dungeons and
Dragons official campaign though I do
think that is a separate question from
the kind of fully original Homebrew type
of situation that we were just talking
about now if you are a big player in the
space like critical role or Dimension 20
there might be some true advantages to
making sure that everything is
officially licensed by Wizards of the
Coast and they might not be able to
avoid it and certainly if you are going
to create your home brews that are not
officially licensed you can't say that
they are officially licensed and you
probably can't use the name Dungeons and
Dragons except in a nominative or
descriptive fair use way in the sense
that you might be able to say something
like this campaign is compatible with
Dungeons and Dragons because even with
trademark restrictions you can describe
a thing by its official name but you're
likely to be able to to compare stuff
and say that this is compatible with the
rules of Dungeons and Dragons you're
just not allowed to say that this is
from Dungeons and Dragons or somehow
officially licensed anyway that's just a
theory a game legal Theory and of course
the situation has now changed Wizards of
the Coast released a statement on DND
beyond.com on January 13th in a
tongue-in-cheek way they said that they
were cognizant of all of the pushback in
quote rolled a one they say that quote
the next ogl will contain the provisions
that allow us to protect and cultivate
the inclusive environment we're trying
to build and specify that it covers only
content for ttrpgs that means that other
Expressions such as educational and
charitable campaigns live streams
cosplay vtt uses Etc will remain
unaffected by any ogl update content
already released under version 1.0 a
will also remain unaffected what it will
not contain is any royalty structure it
also will not include the license back
provision that some people were afraid
was a means for us to steal work that
thought never crossed our minds under
any new ogl you will own the content you
create we won't any language we put down
will be crystal clear and unequivocal on
that point now not only have I been
talking to tons of d d players and GMS
I've also been talking to Wizards of the
Coast lawyers now there's tons of stuff
going on behind the scenes but all the
lawyers will officially say is that
their statement is sincere typical
lawyers just the worst but look it's
great that they listen to the criticism
I'm sure that the changes will mollify a
lot of what people are currently upset
about but I think the point remains if
you're only making content that is DND
compatible and doesn't reproduce their
IP well maybe you never needed to comply
with the ogl in the first place maybe
the real ogl was the friends that we
made along the way smoke bomb
now normally I would not cover a topic
like this this is way too nerdy even for
me and it's way too in the weeds uh
normally a subject like this would be
covered by a fellow YouTube Attorney
Richard Hogue a few days after Christmas
he suffered a stroke was rushed to the
hospital and underwent extensive brain
surgery it seems like he's through the
worst of it but regardless he's going to
have an extensive recovery period and
Richard has always been a straight
shooter and his YouTube channel Hogue
law has always been a resource for
insightful legal commentary on a lot of
legal minutia and his channel as many of
you know is focused on the gaming and
video game industry things that Richard
is incredibly passionate about this is
exactly the kind of video that he would
have loved to have made if he'd been
able to
um his road to recovery is going to be
long his sister has created a GoFundMe
page called reasonable Minds can rebuild
because one of Richard's famous phrases
is that reasonable Minds can differ
because he wasn't afraid to offer an
unpop popular opinion because reasonable
Minds can differ especially when it
comes to the law and that's always been
an incredibly admirable trait of his so
put a link to his GoFundMe page down in
the description and up on screen if
you're able to support it would mean the
world to me so that we can speed along
his recovery because legal commentary on
YouTube is just just a little bit dimmer
without his contributions and then of
course he can deal with all these
freaking nerdy questions about Dungeons
and Dragons and Wizards of the Coast
bunch of nerds cool kids play Magic